Wright's breakfast is one of the most
important meal of the day so I'm putting
the challenge out there to see if
breakfast can be made in ten minutes and
I think I know just the person to
perfect it Mia can you make the
delicious breakfast in ten
welcome to Ramsey in ten hi I'm Mia
Castro and today I'm in Gordon's amazing
kitchen put me up to a challenge to make
breakfast in ten minutes
so today I'm making some cardamom spiced
and orange french toast and I'm gonna
show you all that you don't have to go
to a fancy brunch to have a fancy
breakfast all right so let's do some
time on the clock
and let's get cooking so right here I'm
gonna make the custard to dip the french
toast in I'm gonna put about half a cup
of half-and-half a couple of eggs so
basic French toast ingredients
a little bit of cardamom I love that
warm sort of floral flavor that cardamom
has and I'm gonna do a little bit of
orange zest just make sure when you zest
an orange or any citrus you don't get
all the way down to the pit which is the
white part then we're gonna do a little
bit of vanilla sprinkle of salt let's
get all together let me tell you
something being in this kitchen is so
much easier than house kitchen because I
don't have to worry about Chef Ramsay
yelling down my throat so we have the
custard down and then now I'm gonna make
a crust for the French toast so during
the week this may be a smoothie maker
but today we're gonna use it to make a
restaurant-quality breakfast you have
anyone at home or if you're cooking for
your family or lateness plane doesn't
matter
this will really impress them because it
adds a different element to your french
toast so we're gonna add about I don't
know like a cup or two of corn flakes
and if you don't have this little butter
you can always just put it in a plastic
bag I can just pound it with anything
couple spoonfuls of brown sugar so that
it gets nice and golden and caramelized
and to cardamom throughout the whole -
and there's always just a little bit of
salt
there we go that just goes right next to
the custard then we have a nice brioche
loaf and I like buying the whole loaf so
that I can control the thickness of the
bread and that's what it's gonna make
your french toast look a lot fancier all
that soaks we can start going on the
whipped cream that's gonna go on top of
our french toast and it's really easy
it's just cream a little bit of Grand
Marnier which is orange liqueur and if
you don't have Grand Marnier just orange
zest oh that's just fine I just want to
get fancy it's perfect for the late
night flakes
remember we're trying to do this in ten
minutes so I'm working two things right
now the French toast is soaking so was
your french toast soaks up that nice
custard we're just gonna move it real
quick to our sweet bread crumbs so to
speak then we're going straight to the
pan
well that cuts we're gonna finish our
whipped cream and it's gonna be so much
more impressive than the stuff that you
buy in a can so as soon as you start
getting ribbons like this I'm gonna add
some powdered sugar and I just a little
by little and taste for sweetness so
it's really up to you how much sugar you
have start with be careful not to over
whip it because it'll end up looking
like butter a little separate that
should be good right there how much time
do I have
okay awesome all right so I have one
minute left so I have to get this all
finished it's actually made this at home
one time for my boyfriend one day that
we didn't want to go to brunch and spend
money and I wanted to impress him so I
decided to do a corn flakes and blew his
mind so we've been doing it like this
ever since
these are ready but if you want to make
sure that it's cooked in the middle you
can just throw it in the oven for a
couple minutes and it should be fine so
we're just going straight on the plate
with this and just gonna dust it with a
little bit of powdered sugar
top it off with some of that nice
whipped cream I like to do fresh zest on
top and that's how you make a fancy
breakfast in 10 minutes Gordon please
leave a comment below and let me know
what you thought of my recipe we'll see
you again soon hi I'm Mia Castro I'm in
Gordon's sorry